natasha how are you
morgan very good very happy to be
talking to you to you today
so nice seeing you so listen this is so
wild you have this series that's all
about you
oh my god
how do you feel
i it feels crazy it kind of feels like
kind of surreal because i mean probably
when i was a little girl i used to be
like oh my god you imagine one time when
i started singing and when people know
me then i get to it's crazy it's really
crazy it feels great because i've always
been so private about my life but i feel
like this moment was the moment that i
had to tell uh it's had to make the fans
a part of i feel like it's also a way of
me uh saying that story that part of my
life like the pandemic how i started the
album then i found out that i was
pregnant after i i
knew that i couldn't be uh i worked so
much more on the album like being
pregnant and everything i just feel like
it was a perfect moment of me telling
the story to my fans of what happened
and how it happened but if you have abs
absolutely i mean they're that you just
said so many things that happened to you
in a relatively short amount of time you
know your music has billions of views uh
online you have 70 million social media
followers 34 million on instagram alone
but i can imagine bringing cameras into
your personal life is such a different
experience what was the most challenging
part for you
er
i think in general like just getting
used to
like the final
you know what what were people gonna see
like if you you feel kind of vulnerable
because you're like
you know i i showed things that i
probably wouldn't even show like on a
story on
on my social media uh but um yeah it was
it was a little bit difficult to get
used to uh obviously there were moments
that i was like oh my god is this okay
for me to show you know but at the end
of the day it is i think it's the best
thing because
people need to know nothing natasha they
need to know natalia gutierrez uh
they've been apart they've supported me
for so long and and i hope to inspire
also like other women other girls out
there that want to be uh they want to
have a
family and and are still working and
doing things for themselves you know
that it is possible that you can happy
in all aspects of your life even if
people out there tell you that you can't
you know so i feel like it was also
something that i needed to like stop for
myself because when i found out that i
was pregnant and i'm in the urban uh
world it was like oh you can't be a mom
and be in this world at the same time
and i was like yes i can you know it was
like
it's not her like you know you can't
touch this i'm like yes i can touch it
and i'm gonna touch it and i'm gonna
still be natasha and i'm going to be
proud of being natasha i feel like it's
it's an example that girls out there
have to look at and they can do whatever
they want and i feel like
everybody loves nothing definitely shows
you that yeah can i just say how fierce
you looked when you were performing on
uh jimmy fallon
oh my god jesus christ
you look so good listen
i had that i felt
the most beautiful ever in my life like
i you know they tell you like oh and
your body's gonna change of course it's
gonna change you have a baby inside it's
crazy if it wouldn't change and i felt
so good about it i mean i really wanted
to to for that to happen and i feel like
the combination of everything like me
having to blind out my blinged out belly
showing it and being in a show that i
just dreamt about being i mean i think
it was
just like i felt like it was the
universe and they used to be like watch
if you're if your water breaks i was
like it's gonna be caught on camera it's
gonna be
perfect for a reality show
[Laughter]
you know your fans have been and have
been following you for years you know
this show really does also showcase uh
you being not only a latin singing
sensation but breaking into the english
singing world what's that process been
like for you
it's um
it's i mean it's creative and i feel
like as long as i always enjoy it then
that's the only thing that i have to
care about because if i enjoy it i know
that the people out there are gonna
enjoy the music aren't going to enjoy
the vibe and i know a lot of people that
don't know me are gonna get to know me
and i i'm proud of that you know i feel
like
working working so much and just um
completing all your dreams i mean i have
a bunch of stuff that i still have to do
but it feels cool it feels weird it
feels different so many people that that
you know my music is gonna get to and i
just really hope that they enjoy the
whole ride yeah um who is your dream
artist to collaborate with
lauren hill
i know i actually end up
in the album that i'm working on that i
worked on while i was actually recording
the the docu-series is nothing bad and i
was pregnant so i'm like
i did things that i
didn't dare to do before probably i
don't know what got into me and i
actually touched that song ready or not
from the fuji's i was i've always been a
huge fan of lauren hill lauren he'll be
if you can hear me out there you know
i'm here um
and i touch that song and you know that
when you touch a huge a huge song it
could be a hit or miss and i did it you
know i uploaded a video of a little part
of the song on my social media and like
an hour after i got this producer uh
showing me like a chorus in spanish and
i was like this is meant to be so i did
it i did things in that album that i you
know that i probably wouldn't have done
before in that song
lauren hill has been my
the love of my life forever
oh i love that so much well speaking of
the love of your life uh can we talk
about your man raffy
if what
can we talk about your man right yeah
thank you we can yes we can you can ask
no questions
okay
how do you make it work spending so much
time with him not only as your manager
but of course you share a daughter
together you must really love him
i do i actually do listen
it was a couple of years before we
announced it and i did it i always
wanted to like we were at award shows
and i was like hold my hand it's time
for you to hold my hand a little picture
here and there and it was always
you know it was important that we i feel
like it was important that we didn't say
it at the beginning because it helped
but helped us grow and helped us mature
as a couple probably we would have said
it too early
you know when
in the limelight and i feel like
sometimes that doesn't work very well
but we got to really know each other uh
and i mean once we found out we were
gonna have a family i think it was just
such a positive moment we really truly
love each other and
it took me time to mature and understand
that he was my manager outside of the
house but when we got into the house
if we got any type of disagreement
outside it was like once we go
in that door we can't talk about it and
to me
something that i had to learn i had to
understand and to get used to and i feel
like
we got to that point and it it feels
great i feel i i feel like it's actually
a blessing to have my manager
working with me because it's the only
way a person is going to understand the
type of hours that i have to work
uh raising a baby also like i i just
think it's the best yeah he usually
works behind the scenes so how did he
feel with all the cameras in front of
his face
he
oh he was like oh my god the whole
private thing and then bam once the the
camera's turned on he's like this whole
thing i'm like okay do your thing
do your thing he's very funny uh he's a
very he's a family man so i mean you're
gonna get to see that too and how much
we actually have fun because we actually
do have a lot of fun we love to do it
different activities we love to be in
the water we like we love spending time
with our families with my mom
his aunts everybody so you're gonna see
all of that he loves to cook you know
and i'm here like
great
you're thanks especially when i was
pregnant i was like because i got a
little bit lazy on that i used to cook
outside actually uh when i got pregnant
i wanted to do that whole thing of
cooking outside i don't know why i felt
good so i mean you're gonna get to see
all of that it was great it was great
everybody else he has
has thing things that i probably
wouldn't have showed on my social media
and it was the best way to do it
oh my gosh well congratulations there's
just i mean this is your time to shine i
mean i know you've been doing it for a
long time now but this is a big deal so
congratulations thank you thank you so
much